justin here with a gamespot news updates  sony computer entertainment vp michael  Denny has revealed in a new interview  that sales of the PlayStation 4 have  reached well over 25 million worldwide  speaking with games industry  international den he also said it's an  exciting time to be a PlayStation owner  I don't think there's a better time to  buy into playstation ps4 particularly he  said our install base is now well over  25 million that gives us a massive  community of gamers supported by a lot  of new community features we've got  great games out there more coming  through we're looking forward to 2016  it's an exciting time he didn't announce  an exact figure but that's likely to  come soon as Sony's next earning report  is scheduled for October 29th the  company typically updates sales figures  during these events for the full report  on sony's financials check out gamespot  com